[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mike is
in Phoenix up next Mike welcome to the
show hello how you doing doing pretty
well how are you I'm doing good thanks
for uh taking the call um like listening
to you guys and uh I'm surprised I got a
call in or you know was able to get
accepted so that's cool welcome um yeah
thank you so uh throughout my life um
been a pretty good saver uh followed
Dave Ramsey's uh path and was at baby
step four um but currently uh it's not
looking good um purchased a house last
year and it found out that it's filled
with mold
um and uh it's it's pretty bad um as far
as
options um so right now my family we're
looking at
uh possibly having to walk away from the
home um just because kind of ran out of
options and just you know I like I love
listening to you guys all the time so
just figured you know what U maybe they
might have some advice um on maybe some
next steps to take what are your current
walkway options what what does that look
like short sell H um just because
you know foreclosure would be an option
too but short sell um is definitely
better option from how much damage is it
what what what is the are you getting
quotes on what it would take to
remediate or fix it that's correct yes
it's pretty extensive uh it is I'd be so
underneath you know upside down in the
house if I were to do the repairs is it
everywhere tell me paint the picture
yeah um it is everywhere um there we do
suspect that there was fraudulent
activities going on um in the home prior
um they it was you know it was hidden
pretty good um not pretty good actually
hdden really well and you've got a
professional mold inspection already
done correct and a a
hygienist and you know I did all the
proper precautions uh pre um purchasing
the home and and the home inspector
found a minor spot you know in in an
area that wasn't even um in that General
vicinity so you know that's kind of you
know sometimes you'll find that with
purchases so you know you figured all
right you know that's not you know we
could we could deal with that but then
after um moving in the house within just
a few weeks and things started to show
up you know that weren't in the area of
concern and um just
started getting real concerned so that
at that point you know had a mold um
remediation company come out and do an
invasive inspection just because home
inspections are non-invasive yeah as I
learned you know um so this you're
telling me though the seller knowingly
concealed this mold problem and provided
false
information that's what we're suspecting
if that's the case I would be going to a
real estate attorney I think you've got
you could have a case here what did they
say we've already uh gone down that path
um and then the other thing is just my
concerns like I I want to to speak with
you guys for in regards to way you know
more information I've just been kind of
nervous just because there is a a
process that um I have gone you know
down some of the routes that You' just
discussed so that's one of the things
you know that you know I don't want to
say the wrong thing or you know what I
mean in that in that kind sure I I mean
I don't think you have any recourse here
except legal
recourse right I'd rather you fight this
thing and I in the meantime you're going
to have to find a different living
situation I wouldn't be living in that
house with my
family right yeah but i' would be
looking at all the options and seeing
your legal rights are going to be the
big piece of this equation to see if
they'll you know compensate to basically
gut this home and do the mold
remediation right
and yeah just for for buyers you know I
really am I'm like I'm a nervous buyer
now like I would buying the next home is
gonna is so nerve-wracking yeah you got
some trauma now well but let me say this
I ran into a situation uh with our
current home uh and and and it was a
crazy situation we were just doing some
basic Remodeling and found a wall with a
good amount of mold on it and it was
coming from
an area uh off of the roof that had not
been flashed properly and so once we
figured it out where it was coming from
then we were able to address the
situation and it cost a lot of money I
mean it nowhere near what you're dealing
with but speaking to you moving forward
I mean a really good inspector and
you're checking for it mold comes from
water so where was the water coming from
and and you've got some experience now
so oh yeah it's from fraudulent
activities too that's we suspect that
it's not a natural experience that homes
go through what does that mean my drift
they what you mean are they spraying the
walls on purpose I don't understand what
that
means so as far as what we what we
suspect is you know
uh
growing okay so they have so they have
uh it's not a greenhouse but they were
treating it like a greenhouse and extra
moisture to grow illegal okay there you
go that's a wor that's a worse all right
then so my friend let's focus on the
future here that's all right that's I
need to I need to Future like my future
self let me tell you something you have
all the evidence in the world from these
remediation companies that there is mold
all over the place that was I would you
absolutely have got a you find the right
lawyer who sees the basic evidence as
we've heard it and they get rewarded
when you get rewarded I would absolutely
get a bulldog on this and fight it I
need yeah a lot of the what I've been
learning it's not pro bono too that's
the other thing nobody said pro bono do
you have money to pay for a lawyer
personal injury lawyers get paid on the
back end of situations and so I'm
guarantee you can find a lawyer who goes
we got something here and I'm and I'm
I'm gonna I'm GNA take these clowns to
the bank and and I'll get paid
nicely yeah you you sound like a wounded
wounded dog and I get it oh yeah but
listen but but Mike you you got to fight
for this I
do I definitely have you don't have any
other option don't take it laying down
you got you were you were a victim here
go find a lawyer who sees it is going to
go to the go to the mat for
you yeah definitely so what's the total
mold remediation
cost oh that's Hefty it we're looking at
about three over three that's just
remediation that's not
rebuild over 3
$100,000
yeah yeah that's uh we're not going to
do that what's the house worth I don't
know if I believe that
1.1 it's worth 1.1 it's a big big place
yeah and it's totally covered in mold
they found it every in every wall
infested oh gosh so basically rebuilding
this house from scratch it sounds like
like bulldozer time golly yeah I would
fight this this is big enough that it's
not a it's a stupid tax we're just going
to pay it there's no way who are the do
you know the pre do you know the
previous
owners unfortunately yeah are what are
they reputable people like out there in
the community and this was a side thing
huh yeah I would yeah probably not
they're not probably not I wouldn't yeah
yeah you know what I mean well but I
mean that's my point is if we pursue
suing them like can they even come up
with it exactly that's what I'm dealing
with too that what I've heard is that
you I put a lean on you know the home
and as you guys know uh being well
versed in finances and mortgages and
homes and what and such the mortgage
company gets first so um they're getting
paid before you do man that
is Mike Mike Mike I'm so sorry you're
going through this man this is just a
bum all around I we are not lawyers but
I hope you find a bulldog and you fight
this thing and you call us back with
some good news man we are wishing the
best for you in this mold situation
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life